Speaking, by the way, of understanding math,
I predicted this would happen and it's happening.
We did a video a couple months ago, six weeks
ago called You're About to Get Slammed with
the garbage math.
And in that video, I made the case that after
these massive declines in the stock market,
in employment, job loss, consumer spending,
all of this stuff because of corona virus,
at some point from this insane bottom, you
would start to see a recovery.
And percentage wise, the recovery might look
good.
So you would start to see headlines like and
we have air travel up 120 percent.
Oh, my God.
Hundred and twenty percent.
Well, hold on.
It was down 96 percent to only four percent
of what it was when it goes up.
One hundred and twenty percent.
It's up to nine percent of what it was.
Let's not go crazy, but this is the type of
math that they are going to use to trick you.
And I said it's going to happen with stocks.
It's going to happen with jobs.
And we are seeing it.
Last week, headlines four point eight million
jobs created.
Remember, we lost 46 million jobs.
Four point eight million came back.
Donald Trump went on a national bragging tour
about this is the fastest and best job creation
in the history of the United States.
Well, hold on a second.
First of all, we got four million jobs back
after losing 46 million.
Number two, what did Trump do to actually
get those jobs back?
We would have way more jobs back had we had
a competent federal response to corona virus
rather than what we experienced.
Again, bragging.
Unemployment rate down to 11 percent.
This is the biggest one month drop in unemployment
in history.
Hold on a second.
We had unemployment of 16, 17 percent, real
unemployment arguably 20 percent.
You're bragging now that we still have historically
high unemployment.
And they are doing the full garbage math treatment.
Here's Donald Trump himself just a few days
ago.
The United States economy added almost five
million jobs in the month of June, shattering
all expectations.
I was watching this morning and the expectations
were much lower than that.
The stock market is doing extremely well,
which means to me jobs, what it means, jobs,
the largest monthly jobs gain in the history
of our country.
The unemployment rate fell by more than two
percentage points, down to just about 11 percent.
We're down to the 11 percent number.
We started at a number of very much higher
than that.
As you know, we broke the record last month
and we broke it again this month and an even
bigger way.
This news comes on top of May's extraordinary
jobs report, the largest job gain in history.
Well, it sounds like things are going pretty
well, right?
Oh, wait a second.
We lost 46 million jobs before gaining four
point eight million jobs.
Now, I think this is a good time to remind
you.
I want a good economy.
I don't want any jobs lost in order to hurt
Donald Trump politically.
I don't want any corona virus cases or deaths
to hurt Donald Trump politically.
The reality is, of course, employment is still
well below the pre pandemic level.
We are obviously still in a huge, huge hole
for 15 million fewer jobs in June than in
February.
The unemployment rate is down most recently
from fourteen point seven to eleven point
one at eleven point one.
It is still higher than at any time since
World War Two.
And again, there's a reporting error that
continues to plague these numbers.
The real number is twelve point one.
The data from before this data is from before
the spikes that we've seen in Arizona and
Texas and others.
Texas is sort of softening their opening,
telling a lot of people that they should stay
home.
So let's see where things look in another
month or two if the pandemic continues to
explode.
And, you know, the realistic expectation is
we would see slow improvement to the numbers
as we get closer to the end of 2020.
And we are in all likelihood, going to start
2021 in a significantly worse position than
we started 2020.
That's the reality.
So do not fall for the garbage math.
The Eckardt the.
What I think is missing from a lot of these
analysis is the economy can't fully recover
mathematically until the pandemic is under
control.
What I mean by that is until people get all
their earnings back, they don't have the money
to buy stuff at the rate at which they were
previously.
That's just math, that simple math if you
don't have as much money as you did before.
You can't spend as much money as you were
spending before.
Until hospitals can do non-emergency procedures
in full, the medical health care industry
is not going to recover.
Now, I think our industry is a complete, immoral
joke.
The reality is that it's a huge industry that
makes a lot of money until people are going
back to the doctor the way they were before
for elective and non-emergency procedures.
The industry mathematically cannot recover
until then and dine out.
Restaurants are fully open and safe.
Restaurants can't recover.
It's just math.
If people aren't going back and the capacity
is diminished, the industry cannot recover.
It's just simple arithmetic.
And we've not even started to see the fall
semester at colleges and universities, depending
on how that goes.
You could see massive economic fallout in
the 2021 academic year there.
So do not be tricked.
I want things to recover as quickly as possible.
But until we actually have the pandemic under
control from a straight up math perspective,
it cannot happen.
It simply cannot happen.